he is from NBC Sports he hosts the Peter
King podcast he is the NFL insider for
football night in America I'm the author
of football morning in America the must
read every single day after the Sundays
in your football season he is Peter King
how you been Peter Rich everything's
going well thank you okay
and you're kind enough to call him in
the show of for our Honda insider report
and my thought for my first question for
you is what do you think of my list of
MVP candidates right there six all the
way up to one what do you think well I
would have Lamar Jackson to I would have
him with his hot breath all over Russell
Wilson's neck but I definitely think
Wilson's the MVP I think I think Jackson
is close
I think Aaron Jones is play slightly
diminishes the case of Aaron Rodgers and
I think soon I don't know exactly when I
agree with you about the Shaun Watson I
would have deshaun Watson 3 I'd have
McCaffrey 4 and I would have several
people 5 among them Patrick mahomes
Aaron Rodgers I I don't know you know at
this time of year you can list a lot of
guys but at the end of the day I think
you said it about about running backs
you have to really have a generational
season to be more important than any of
the 26th quarter or any of the 32
quarterbacks in the NFL and so that's
why we'll probably the vast majority of
MVPs for the rest of our lives will be
quarterbacks
so what did we learn more from week 10
do we learn more about the Seahawks and
Niners or more about the Saints Peter
based off of week tens action I think
every team during the course of most
years you see the Patriots they've had
some very ugly double digit losses in
almost every year that they won the
Super Bowl so unless the Saints show me
at some point in
the next two or three weeks when they
play Tampa Bay Carolina and Atlanta
again if they show me in the next three
weeks that what happened in Atlanta
against Atlanta and Sunday was not a
fluke then I'll be worried about him but
I'm not worried about them I think teens
sometimes just have games like that I
think the thing that I would take away
from this week
most notably is that the Seattle
Seahawks are not going away and Russell
Wilson is so far and away and again I
this is going to sound stupid but I
think he's so far in a way the MVP in
the league based on the fact that you
know if you look at his talent I'm
telling you last night in overtime on
the first play of overtime he threw a
pass and completed it to a guy named
Turner who I never heard of before I
have no idea who he was I had to look
him up I think his name is Malik Turner
I didn't know what he was and and so and
and and then you know he's got two huge
passes down the stretch to Josh Gordon
who just walked into the locker room
about 10 minutes ago
I just think what he did last night even
with the interception even including the
interception which was a Dwight Clark
type fingertip catch you know by that 22
year old linebacker Greenlaw of the of
the Niners I just think what he did was
extraordinary I think on the other hand
I think Jimmy Garoppolo is a cause for
concern rich why is that I because he
was awful I you know he had so many
moments that should have been big
moments that he didn't respond to now he
did have some drop balls but the biggest
drop ball of the night was by KJ right
you know which would have ended the game
even before the game was supposed to end
most likely you know in overtime I just
I was worried about how Garoppolo played
a huge moment the first I have to say
probably the first huge moment of his
NFL career he had big you know that the
Sunday night game where he replaced
Brady a couple of years ago in Arizona
that was a big moment the game last
night was a huge moment and he did not
he was not equal to that moment well I
guess Peter King here on the Rich Eisen
show in the Honda inside a report I
guess to play devil's advocate here I
mean Kittel wasn't in the game and he
lost Emmanuel Sanders in the first
quarter of that game the running game
was stopped and your former colleague
and my current accurate though right was
just he was in an accurate I understand
everybody is going to have some injuries
to their team and again I'm not saying
that this is this is a trend a pattern
anything I'm just saying that really
raised eyebrows with me how Jimmy
Garoppolo played in big moments in this
game it wasn't good I guess sure I mean
conversely as you pointed out that
Russell Wilson is throw in to a guy who
required a name tag for most all of us
and we are observers of the league
professionally I mean there was one
point booger McFarland pointed out that
Josh Gordon wasn't on the field for a
crucial play meaning he probably didn't
know it yet that they're probably
running a play that he's not familiar
with yet and that's how Russell weaves
it all in also Jim Trotter your former
colleague my current colleague at the
NFL Network said that Bobby Wagner after
the game told him that they were fit he
and KJ Reich began picking up on Jimmy
Garoppolo sex which allowed them to
break faster on the ball they certainly
looked like they were all over the
passes Peter that's for sure last night
I think so too rich I think that I think
something was going on in that game that
just didn't smell right about Garoppolo
in the passing game but Rich I'll also
say one other thing sure and this is a
hundred and twenty degrees different
than what we're talking about but I
think it's important and I wanted to get
this point across I want you to think
about last night and and think about
these players on the Seattle Seahawks
and what they have in common okay
Jacob Hollister Josh Gordon did
clowny quandary digs and why I like this
franchise and the way it operates under
John Schneider so much okay they've got
a quarterback who's fine you just tell
them what the rules are and what we have
and he'll make it work he looked like he
looked like Tom Brady and Rob Gronkowski
last night with Jacob Hollister who you
know obviously is in his first year
there is first few weeks there honestly
Josh Gordon just got there too huge
third down conversions one on Richard
Sherman in overtime right with Gordon um
yeah Clowney was clowny was probably
played the best game of his life
quandary digs with a huge interception
after getting there at the trading
deadline
I don't rich I there's a lot about this
game last night that said to me in the
modern NFL when a lot of times you have
to make it up on the fly almost give me
John Schneider Pete Carroll and Russell
Wilson and I'll take on the rest of the
league Peter King here on the Rich Eisen
show on the Honda inside a report this
dovetails and works perfectly Chris into
our poll question for the day ask ative
Peter can go for it yeah Peter who's the
best team in the NFC 49ers Seahawks
Packers Saints that's we only have four
because we're putting it on Twitter if
you want to throw the Vikings into this
conversation Peter feel free go for it I
mean I I just think it's a this is a
fool's errand I mean I will pick New
Orleans but I would make an argument and
a good argument for all four of them
that's why the NFC and the NFL is going
to be so fun down the stretch
you know why rich listen look at San
Francisco schedule they play Green Bay
they play at New Orleans they play at
Seattle's to do look at New Orleans they
host San Francisco and and looking
look at Green Bay they got a play at
Minnesota and they're playing at San
Francisco it all of these teams we're
gonna know who's good at the end it's
one of the reasons why rich and again
let's go 120 degrees a different all
right I must say I had this thought for
a split second I said oh no way no way
when see it when San Francisco got the
ball with Seattle having no timeouts
with a minute 50 to go Jimmy Garoppolo
is having sort of a shaky time you know
and as big guys are not out there mm-hmm
there's a minute 50 to go there's no
timeouts for Seattle you're they're at
their own 24 a 1/2 a second I thought
yep does it make any sense right here to
just kneel on the next three plays and
run out the clock and take the tie
because honestly when you think about it
right now they lost the game they have a
half game lead for NFC supremacy right
now a half game lead over Seattle in
Green Bay who were both able to now if
they had tied they would have a two-game
lead is lost policy for any team in the
NFC Peter we were talking about at the
top of our show it's just even though
Carl Shanahan is rightfully called as
sharp as he is he is it's so difficult
to gameplan or prepare yourself to be
placed in that situation when you know a
good playing for the tie is thoroughly
unsatisfactory to every man woman and
child in that building or in an owner's
suite
I don't know manager you do it I don't
suggest that you do it
I'm just saying it's the most
fascinating thing right that comes out
of this game last night
well before I let you go here the one
team that's missing and rightfully so
from this conversation is the Dallas
Cowboys I will give you the floor on the
question that I get asked on this show
when I'm chatting with my friends or
people that just wanted to know you know
come up to me and want to know why are
the Cowboys five and four Peter what
would be the answer to that question why
are they five and four well in a tech
since I would say that their biggest
issue this year is that their offensive
line might have the same people most of
the same people playing they're not
playing the same as the clastic you know
as as you'd think that Tyron smith and
and and and those guys playing together
in tandem they're not playing as well as
they did so therefore they can't
dominate a game on offense on the using
the running game Ezekiel Elliott is
having a nice year he's not having you
know a sixteen hundred yard rushing year
that the Cowboys want to have their
offense built around okay that's number
one and number two I just think that we
overestimated the Cowboys have some very
good players and some good talent but we
overestimated them a little bit at the
beginning of the year and I think that
having said all that I don't think it's
going to matter I think at the end of
the year if they're a wild-card team or
are they losing the first round of the
playoffs or whatever
I think Jason Garrett is probably going
to go and it might be time for him to go
this is getting to be a stale team with
a lot of talent and they might they
might need to be you know taken by the
scruff of the neck and shaken up a
little bit then who's the one to do that
who would do a judge forever they did
it'd be Shawn TEI try some point right
but now apparently Sean Payton who I
think is like is probable now to become
the Chuck Noll of New Orleans
I think he's got I think there are two
coaches right now you know I think have
a really good chance to beat Chuck Noll
and that's Harbaugh in Baltimore and I
mean as obviously as well as Mike Tomlin
earth-2 right Harbaugh Tomlin and and
and now after he signed his extension in
New Orleans Sean Payton I don't know who
it is
with there anyway they can they can they
can get a like a David Shaw to leave
Stanford or you know can they get
Lincoln Riley I I can't answer that I
don't I don't know I mean I actually
have as well
those guys that question and but I do
think that both of them are inclined to
stay where they are and he does he go
does Jerry go very non famous and do a
mad either flu sir maybe do what josh
mcdaniels or do I mean I don't know what
he would do if he ended up getting rid
of Jason Garrett but I think he will be
tempted to go famous because that's
Jerry's way but I have no idea who
they'd end up picking and Steelers a
couple wins away from Mike Tomlin being
the leader in your coach of the year
clubhouse when you agree with that Peter
he's I think Hey look I've always
thought this but his winning percentage
with the Steelers is far above Knoll and
significantly above Bill Cowher and yet
he's terminally unappreciated and yeah I
mean of course he could have won another
Superbowl let's say but you can say that
about a lot of teams in the NFL
I just think Mike Tomlin has control of
his team and now especially without a
Antonio Brown without Le'Veon Bell they
get to build a team the way they wanted
and you know what rich I'll just say one
other thing
I believe that when they lost Ben
Roethlisberger that was a motivating
force for them to say okay we are
building defense on this team and that's
why in my opinion it was a driving force
into them going to trade their 2020
number one for Minka Fitzpatrick he's
been here's gotta say right now that
that looks like a great decision by
Kevin Colburn hey and and and this
year's version in a way of the Amari
Cooper trade right where you're like
what are you doing throwing a number one
in next year's draft for something for a
player that one can help you now I I
would I would agree rich but I think the
mink of Fitzpatrick one is going to turn
out to be more valuable just based on
well based on if you look at the way
these teams are playing the Cowboys are
so in and out that has very little to do
with a Marty Cooper but I think the b12
shot that makeup is bad
gave the Pittsburgh Steelers has been
consistently over his first wherever it
is seven games in Pittsburgh
significantly more impactful than the
average weekly impact that that Amari
Cooper has had an that has been
significant that was not a bad trade I
just think that it looks to me right now
today that the mink of Fitzpatrick trade
is going to turn out to be more
impactful for Pittsburgh Peter always
appreciate it always love our chats look
forward to the next one already thank
you for the call butter
thanks a million rich you take care
that's Peter King at Peter underscore
King on Twitter I follow me a must
follow for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app